Speaker 1: . Let's hear from some people
in the audience. We take calls via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord. Make sure
that you set your nickname in the waiting lobby,
too, your name and where you're calling from.
Those are the rules. Nicknames, etc. are not
welcome. Let's go first to Tyrone from Ohio.
Tyrone, welcome. What's on your mind today?
Tyrone, welcome. What is on your mind today, my
friend? You got to set your audio device to the
appropriate one. And Tyrone. Last chance. What is
going on, my friend? What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hello.
Speaker 1: Can you? Yes,
now I can hear you. Tyrone, what's going on?
Speaker 2: Okay. So like things in Ohio,
they're getting real bad. And I'm wondering
like instances when what do you think is next?
What is the game plan?
Speaker 1: If DeSantis becomes premier
of the United States, you're saying?
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: Well, that was worth skipping ahead.
I mean, first he's got to become the nominee.
You know, your question depends on what
exactly is happening in January of 2025
when a hypothetical DeSantis presidency would
start. What's on your mind? What specifically
is getting bad in Ohio that you're worried about?
Speaker 2: Oh. I mean, just the name itself. It's
already kind of bad, but, you know,
just like a it seems like dystopian
future would be most ideal if it became
president. I'm just wondering, like,
what's the direction of the country if he does?
Speaker 1: Well, it's going to continue in this
sort of like modern I think what we're calling
it is reactionary populist direction. And it's
not going to be about policy. It's
not going to be about helping people.
It's not going to be about improving the
country. It's going to be about culture,
war issues and reactionary populism and some
authoritarianism sprinkled in. And unfortunately,
DeSantis is arguably more dangerous than Trump
because he's less incompetent. But let's you know,
let's first deal with the primaries, I would say,
just to not get ahead of ourselves. And we've
got local elections coming up in 2023. So there's
still a lot of work to do. Before we get to that,
let's let Republicans have their primary
first, then we'll worry about DeSantis.
Tyrone. All right, Tyrone. Thank you very
much for the call. An important question